hi today I'd like to introduce a new
module in previous modules we've talked
about how to model particular systems
how to make predictions about certain
kinds and classifications of systems and
also how to design both theoretical and
physical systems if our systems are
operating in a deterministic universe
then we're all set we've accounted for
all the things we can possibly account
for but if we're making systems that are
going to operate in the real world then
we need to be able to deal with some
level of uncertainty today I'm going to
talk about probability which is the
method by which we're going to model
uncertainty in our world and later we're
going to talk about different strategies
we can take to deal with that
uncertainty to hopefully increase the
level of autonomy of our systems as they
operate in the world the first thing I
need to talk about is how to properly
model probability or how to talk
properly talk about probability such
that we can use it to talk about in
certainty when you're talking about
probability typically you'll end up
talking about the sample space or you
this refers to your entire universe
where your universe is the values that
you care about or the possible assigned
values of the variables that you care
about I'm already talking about
variables but what I really need to say
is events there are different states
that your universe can take and those
states can be sort of exhaustively
enumerated or be atomic or they can be
factored into different variables let me
elaborate on this a little
if I were talking about for coin flips
if those events were specified
atomically then I would have to
exhaustively specify all possible
sequences of four coin flips right four
heads three heads in one tail three had
two heads and two tails that sort of
exercise or flipping four heads would be
one event flipping three heads and then
one tail would be a separate event
flipping two heads one tail and another
head would be a third distinct event if
we're talking about a factored state
space then we'll have a different
variable representing each one of these
coin flips and each one of those
variables will say here's you know
here's the value associated with that
particular sub event and the
accumulation of all those values or the
specification for all those values will
end up referring to the same states that
were addressed by the atomic events all
right let me talk about variables
because they're the thing that allow us
to not exhaustively enumerate every
possible event in the universe and talk
about our universe in meaningful ways or
in in ways that are effectively that can
be effectively communicated and why why
am I talking about random variables why
don't they just random variables well
random variables is the way that you
specify the fact that you're talking
about probabilistic variables when
you're just dealing with regular algebra
variables have some sort of assigned
value and it's not you're not forced to
be in the space of 0 to 1 when you're
talking about from 0 to 1 when you're
talking about probabilities you're
forced to be in the space of 0 to 1 and
forced to remain within the reals
if you want to talk about all the
possible assigned values of that random
variable then you're talking about the
distribution over that random variable
this means that a could be any anything
that a you know anything that a could be
right your your you're talking about the
function that says give me a value of a
and I will tell you a probability
associated with that value of a if
you're talking about the probability of
a being assigned to a particular value
then you'll return out the probability
right if if a represents the color of
the shirt I'm wearing and the
probability that a is some value I want
to know the probability that a is some
value then I look at the color of the
shirt I'm wearing and try to determine
whether or not it's 1 or 0 or possibly
look at the colors of shirts that I've
worn over the past year and make some
sort of make some sort of ratio of you
know the number of pink shirts I've worn
over the past year
if I'm dealing with a factored
state-space I'm going to end up talking
about more than one random variable
there are two main ways to talk about
more than one random variable at the
same time one is joint probabilities
where all the random variables are
collectively specified at the same time
and the other is conditional
probabilities where you've already
decided that you've specified some value
for a one or more random variables and
then within that scope you're going to
talk about the probabilities associated
with other random variables I want to
demonstrate this graphically but there
are two more things that I need to
mention right now one is the difference
between the for Clinton frequentist and
Bayesian interpretations of probability
right now they don't seem particularly
relevant but people will use these words
and it's good to know approximately what
they're talking about the frequentist
interpretation of probability is more
relevant when you're talking about
actions that happen a lot of different
times for instance how frequently it
rains if I say that today is Wednesday
and I want to know the probability that
it rains on Wednesdays then that
probability is open to for cuentas
interpretation because there are a lot
of wednesdays and it's rained a lot in
the universe of wednesdays or the the
space of possible wednesdays so thinking
about the fact that there's a 70% chance
of rain or a 30% chance of rain or
whatever probability of rain there is on
wednesdays makes sense or is open to
frequentist interpretation the other
interpretation that you'll hear talked
about with respect to probability is the
Bayesian interpretation Bayesian
interpretation tends to be more relevant
when you are talking about spaces that
are more atomic as opposed to factored
or represent events that are specified
to the point that it does not make sense
to talk about them in the in in the
frequentist sense
when we talk about probabilities in the
Bayesian interpretation we frequently
use the term likelihood for instance if
I'm talking about whether or not it's
likely to rain on August 24th 2011 in
the afternoon the specificity of that
event is so high that at that point it
doesn't make sense to talk about the
frequency of Wednesday August 24th 2011
in the afternoons at least for now at
that point we're talking more about
likelihood and less about frequency that
event is more conducive to Bayesian
interpretation no whirlwind tour of
probability would be complete without a
mention of the three axioms of
probability the first axiom is that the
likelihood of the universe happening is
one or all random variables are going to
be specified at some point relatedly
they likely to have nothing happening to
zero what these two really do is
establish the boundaries of the
graphical representation up here the
other axiom of probability is that if
you're going to be talking about the
union of two events or the probability
associated with one or the other event
having an assignment then you're talking
about the probability of that of one of
those variables and the probability of
the other variable and then removing the
section that you've double counted so if
I were to attempt to demonstrate this on
this graph I would be talking about the
probability of a added the probability
would be at this point I've double
counted this section in the middle or
they're both one so I would subtract
this exactly once and then I'm talking
about the size of this space
if I'm talking about the probability of
a being equal to one then I'm talking
about the space in which a is specified
to be equal to 1 divided by the area
associated with my universe
when I'm talking about joint
distributions I'm going to find the
space in which both of these things are
true scoped to the size of the universe
or the entire sample space so in this
space both a and B are true and I'm
looking at it relative to the size of
the universe
in contrast what I'm talking about
conditional probability or the
probability of a given B I'm going to
look at where my specifications are true
scoped to wear my Givens are true so if
I'm already dealing in the space
restricted to be I'm just looking at
this size or this space but because I'm
scoped to B I'm going to end up dividing
by the area of B instead of the area of
you
Oh
this is the main difference between the
joint and conditional distributions and
a lot of people get hung up on it which
is why I'm exhaustively walking through
it all right a couple of the things
before we talk about the first way in
which we can use our models for
uncertainty to do some amount of
addressing of the fact that we're going
to have to deal with uncertainty in the
future if we start off with a Joint
Distribution and we want to reduce the
number of variables that we're actually
talking about we can do so by
exhaustively walking through all the
possible assigned values for the
variable that we want to disregard and
then summing up the values appropriately
an easy example for this is if we had
the joint probabilities of all the
colors of shirts that I wear and all the
colors of pants that I wear and we only
wanted to talk about all the colors of
shirts that I wear then we could
exhaustively cover all the different
colors of pants that I wear and
accumulate all the different values of
shirts that I wear simultaneously and
then collect that distribution related
is the concept of total probability
which is the same kind of accumulation
it just keeps track of the fact it just
operates in the conditional space as
opposed to in the joint space so in this
case if I'm already operating in and you
know a given B Wheatland
I have to scope myself back out to the
space of the universe by then accounting
for the fact that I've only been
operating in the scope of B then
exhaustively enumerate all the possible
values of B some of the probabilities
associated with those values and then
I've reduced the number of
mentions that I'm talking about the
final thing we have to talk about before
we move on to state estimation is called
Bayes evidence or you've probably seen
this demonstrated his Bayes rule if I
want to talk about be scoped to a and
all I have is a scoped to be B and a
when we watch through total probability
we saw that the conditional probability
multiplied by the probability associated
with the variable that we're
conditioning on is equal to the joint
probability when we multiply a given B
by P of B or P of a given B by P of B
we're going to end up with the joint
probability associated with the two
variables when we then divide back out
by a or scope our joint probability to a
we end up we end up talking about
conditional probabilities again which is
where be given a comes from base
evidence or Bayes rule is the basis for
inference which is going to be really
important for state estimation which
we'll cover next time